après cinq heures de délibéré les jurés
ont répondu oui à toutes les questions
le procureur avait requis huit ans de
prison à l'encontre d'antonio sharek et
si la peine prononcée est légèrement
inférieure ce n'est pas le plus
important aux yeux des avocats de la
partie civile qui représentait les
quatre fils de m gül
ça fait cinq ans que les filles de
patrick dumont attendent qu'une
juridiction reconnaissent qu
effectivement elles sont les victimes du
comportement d'un homme qui sans l'avoir
voulu savoir voulu le résultat a
volontairement commis des violences qui
a entraîné la mort de leur père je ne
souhaitais pas de peine en particulier
le ce que je souhaitais c'est
qu'effectivement les rôles soit
judiciairement établi
elles sont victimes parce que monsieur
richard heck est coupable des faits de
violences volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort sans intention de la donner sur la
personne d'un avocat dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
pour la défense m e nicolas plaider la
thèse d'un accident
il avait d'ailleurs demandé une contre
expertise qui estimait que le choc
traumatique à la tête de l' avocat
pouvaient avoir été causés simplement
par sa chute sous l'effet de la surprise
mais la propre épouse d'anthony m'charek
avant de se rétracter avait elle-même
décrit les coups portés par son mari
celui ci a désormais dix jours pour
faire appel